on this point of the ironic satanist
this is just a minor point before we
move on
i was reminded when i was reading about
these ironic satanists of this story
that didn't get a ton of play mike
cernovich uh posted it around again
recently too that at cern
you know the large hadron collider this
probably the most important site for
physics research on earth
there was a film that leaked of a of a
satanic
performed human sacrifice like a sort of
a show ritual not a real human sacrifice
but a feigned
satanic ritual
at cern in front of a hindu deity
and you look you can watch the video
it's really it's it's real there's
people in these black robes
with fire all around and then a light on
i think it's a statue of shiva and then
a a performed human sacrifice and she
said what
what the hell
is what are these scientists doing and
then cern made a statement about it
and they said oh
yeah the footage
was recorded as part of a prank by
scientists at europe's top physics lab
cern said that the ritual was just it
was just researchers and scientists
coming to work at the facility and
taking their sense of humor a little too
far
yeah it's not a big it's just a big
funny ha ha it's just a funny little
hoax joke you know you know when you
joke you know you go out with friends
and you maybe you throw a couple back
you have one too many coca-colas and
then you perform a black mass in front
of a hindu deity and you pretend to
sacrifice a human being huh you know and
then maybe when you shoot some pool
afterward
maybe you gamble a little bit too much
and you worship moloch and ball in the
devil you know how that happens ha
you jokester
you owe you with your dry sense of humor
i don't know about you that that
explanation doesn't suffice for me
i'm gonna need a little bit more
before i just write this off
this is you know gosh you've got
you've got gay frogs
you've got weird stuff in the water that
the epa just admitted now you've got
devil worshipers at cern this is
this is really shaking a lot of
what what i had believed previously
about
how normal politics is
if if you do that if you engage in black
satanic rituals
ironically and
it's it's not ironic okay and it's bad
and it and the fact that this symbolism
uh continues to exist
is and has existed for millennia that
should tell you something if you're if
you're on the side with the guys in the
dark black robes and the fire performing
the human sacrifices you're on the wrong
side get on a different side okay
right now go to ring.com
it's the summer people are going to be
traveling a lot you see i'm in a hotel
room right now i'm traveling when you're
traveling whether you're traveling alone
whether you're traveling with your
family you want to keep your house safe
okay you want to keep your family safe
yourself safe all that stuff so that's
why you need a ring you know about rings
video doorbell where you can see and
speak to people wherever you are in the
house outside the house on the other
side of the world you know about ring
alarm rings award-winning alarm system
now you got to go pro okay now is the
time it is it's the time to go pro be a
pro just like me
ring alarm protects your doors your
windows your whole physical home ring
alarm pro protects your digital home as
well
think of how much of your life you live
on the internet would you protect your
physical documents would you protect all
your financial documents would you maybe
shred them put them in a safe place well
if you would do that why wouldn't you
protect your digital life where you've
got so much more information protect the
whole thing ring is the way to do it
cnet calls it a giant leap for home
security go pro be a pro like me head on
over to ring.com
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s that is ring.com
knowles the transgenderism is demonic
it's the only way to describe it it is a
way i'm not saying that the people who
are under the sway
of transgenderism and in the thrall of
this ideology are intentionally
worshiping demons but it is a demonic
influence that tells you that your soul
and your body are in opposition to one
another and you've got to mutilate
yourself it's just so anti-human it's
just so extremely destructive
and that
whatever whatever we know about the
devil we know
we know two things we know he's a liar
and we know that he hates life he
specifically hates human beings
and so when people are really anti-human
when they're really anti-life
and when they ground their ideas on
manifest lies
you gotta sense that the old the old
devil might be lurking around somewhere
and you probably want to get on the
other side
on this point of transgenderism
and demonic policy there is a new policy
from fina the international swimming
association that is
it's being reported in some some places
as being really good for the
conservative side and really tough on
the transgender side
because they're they're tightening up
the rules and they're saying look these
dudes can't just willy-nilly compete
against the women because they're
they're going to beat all the women and
so
they're they're going to have to
uh
they're going to have to have
transitioned
before a certain age if they
transitioned before the age of 12
then they can compete against the women
but if they transitioned after they
can't do that and then fina is going to
try to create an open category for these
sort of sexually confused people to
compete against one another that isn't
the male category
or isn't the the female category
this is a bad idea
they're trying to split the baby on this
and it's not going to work
first did you catch what the worst part
of this policy is
did you get it's the it's right there at
the top
if you transition before the age of 12
then
you can compete against the women what
does that do that creates an incentive
to transition to go on puberty blockers
and cross-sex hormones and chop up your
body before the age of 12.
what happens when you get when you
create incentives you get more of that
behavior so the result of this policy is
going to be an increase in the number of
poor little kids who get their bodies
all chopped chopped up and their lives
ruined so that their psycho parents can
get them to compete in the swimming race
where they think they're going to win
and get a scholarship
that's the first part of it
second part of it
this open category
just punts the question it says well
yeah we just don't want to rule on it
and so yeah men they're not men they are
men they're not women you you can't you
can't split the baby
on this okay you have to come to an
answer and the reason that people don't
want to come to an answer is because
they're squishes and because
they're cowards in some way and because
maybe they don't have moral clarity and
also because they don't realize
how
common how much common sense ordinary
people have we are inundated with this
crazy transgender idea from every corner
and so we think that it's a common
popular belief it's not the vast
majority of people know this is
completely insane
you can say that you can have confidence
in fact if you say that you're going to
be more politically popular you're going
to win more elections you're going you
might be attacked by some of the
prevailing institutions but the people
are going to be on your side and they're
going to be on your side because it's
right either a man is
a man and not a woman or a man is not
necessarily a man and can be a woman
you've got to pick though
and if if it's the latter if you can
really be a woman born in a man's body
or vice versa
then then we need to trans the kids
and then that's fine and then we can
incentivize it below the age of 12 or
even younger because it's true right
then it actually would be cruel to let
the kids go through puberty
but if it's fake which we all know it is
if it's just completely absurd which we
all know it is
then you shouldn't do it at 12 or 14 or
20 or 75
it's wrong and destructive
we haven't lost this issue
there are some conservatives who want to
preemptively surrender this issue
because they're the surrender party
because they're the john cornyn party
because they're giving in on very
important issues not just gender talk
about gun rights talking about
constitutional rights without any need
to whatsoever but we haven't lost this
issue we haven't even lost marriage by
the way
we we just radically redefined marriage
in this country the supreme court did
within the last decade
changed the definition a marriage to
something that is completely
unrecognizable from all of human history
and then what happened the squishes
right away they said okay it's over move
on time to move on they're all the
squishes were thrilled when the supreme
court redefined marriage it's over gotta
move on it's not over guys it's not over
actually people are still
people are still standing up on this
issue because
because the truth is on our side i'm
glad you like that clip now this is very
very important don't hop up nope
ring that bell subscribe like ding dong
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe head on over to my myspace
page i don't know go everywhere we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you